hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech career and
life so as you may know i'm someone who
came up to software engineering
through pretty traditional methods and
paths
who then went on to silicon valley to
work as a software engineer
building products but i do think that
one of the best parts about coding in
software engineering is that you can't
apply it to anything
but because of the path that i've taken
and the people that i've met through my
path
sometimes it's hard for me to imagine
all the other ways you can use
code like i had questions about how do
you get into other fields with coding
is coding a natural part of the field or
have people figured out ways to
use coding as part of their job and like
what technologies do they use what
skills are important and how has
technology changed the way that they
work
so welcome to like a new show or segment
or series that i'm tentatively calling
the merge
where i talk to someone who uses coding
in a way that you might not expect
i'm actually not sure how this will go
or where it'll go or if it's going to
continue but i figured
why not try and see how things go
specifically today we're going to talk
about the intersection of
coding and glaciers that's right
glaciers like the big
chunks of ice i recently met someone
through my twitch stream who told me
that he uses coding and the pomodoro
method to do his work
in glaciology and i was just so
intrigued by that because i never even
thought about using coding and
technology in a field like that so i
wanted to learn more
i hosted this as a live stream a couple
weeks ago and so today i'm going to
bring you some of the highlights and the
best parts of that conversation
to you and so before we dive in and talk
to michael shaheen
my friend who is a phd student in
glaciology
i wanted to thank the sponsor of today's
video skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community for creatives where millions
come together to take the next step in
their creative journey
skillshare is for real working creatives
and lifelong learners
their classes include a combination of
video lessons and a class project
and their classes fit to your schedule
and skill level most classes are under
an hour and members get unlimited access
to thousands of inspiring classes with
hands-on projects and
feedback from a community of millions
and so maybe some of you are starting
off in your coding journey this year
and i recommend a course by rich
armstrong called
hand coding your first website html and
css basics
html and css is a great place to start
and so definitely check out his course
only the first 1000 of my subscribers to
click the link in the description
we'll get a free trial of premium
memberships so you can explore your
creativity
thanks again to skillshare for
sponsoring and now let's dive in and
learn about glaciers
like i said more of a textbook
definition of what is glaciology i would
just say it's simply the study
of ice sheets and glaciers how ice
moves changes and evolves throughout
time simply put glaciology
so i was actually a computer science
major when i entered my undergraduate
and to make that even more i kind of
wanted to be a software engineer
in high school i think my sophomore year
that's why i took like my first
anything like programming or yeah so i i
was kind of on that track
and so i started as a computer science
major it was about three semesters in
i was like i'm actually kind of tired of
this and my intro geology professor was
like oh there's some really interesting
overlap with computer scientists
and then earth science and again it's
kind of like that image you had it was
like someone in antarctica was like
doing cool doing something cool with
like an instrument yeah
i would say but there's some instrument
there and i was like wow that's actually
kind of the
questions i'm like looking at i wanted i
wanted to shift something a little
less of a i guess an artificial science
like something that's not physical
and something more physical based and i
was curious about climate change and i
thought that was an interesting
intersect i could do because i felt
confident on a computer like i took
python
you know java and all this i talked to
my
future advisor in geology he was like do
you like satellites
sounds like i have nothing against them
and that's kind of how i got started
in a geology and and i was actually
researching
in the virgin islands as an undergrad so
not
polar regions at all virgin islands is
pretty tropical isn't it
it's in the caribbean yeah so there's no
ice
there's no ice
geographic information systems and
remote sensing so essentially like i was
mapping and modeling
chlorophyll distribution in around coral
reefs with respect to
coral bleaching and climate change i got
kind of bored of that too
honestly and i kind of found glaciology
on my own i just
i there's a few textbooks in the the
college of charleston where i got my
undergrad in
in the glaciers and glaciation the
physics of glaciers they had these two
books and i was taking a structural
geology course and that's about faults
think about like fault and like rocks
rubbing against each other which is
essentially a glacier sliding on its bed
and i kind of just fell in love with it
since then
it's booked from the library i was like
oh this is really sweet yeah and then
now you're doing your phd in it now i'm
doing my phd kind of cold call
cold emailed my potential advisors like
hey you do really cool stuff
do you have a spot for me wow and she
was like there's this really cool lidar
system we have a hellhound glacier
do you know about light i was like yeah
i'm so familiar with lidar she's like
you're wrong i was like
wait this is such like a like one thing
led to another
and now i'm doing glaciers kind of story
and so like that that um geology course
that you were taking as an undergrad was
that just kind of like a
general education requirement like
that's the most common thing that people
at your university were taking
so okay first my day-to-day yeah yeah
day in the life of a
student in graciology let's do this
aside from getting ready for the day
i'll say my first working
bit would be i try to read or write in
the morning i just feel
more motivated to do that so catching up
the literature
writing a proposal or after lunch that's
when i get more technical and i
get in my get my ide i use spider if
people are interested in
whatever ids i use and this is a python
a scientific python environment
um it depends on i guess what task i'm
at so with processing the lidar
the point clouds if anyone's not
familiar with lidar it's um it's in the
new iphone
12 pro mac it's a laser that essentially
shoots lasers at a surface and it
bounces back and then you can calculate
the two-way travel time and
from that distance you can know the
position so you have a collection of
points
that represent a three-dimensional
surface and that's a point cloud that's
what light up produces i use
numpy pandas scipy matplotlib for
visualizations
if not seaborne or something and then
getting more into the
geographic or more geospatial packages
gdal the geospatial data abstraction
library
pdoll i call it poodle that's how it was
introduced to me the same thing with g
dolls for point clouds
and those are the tools i typically use
on a day to day what i do with that um
calculate um displacements between
points um i make
digital elevation models the m's that
are just more of a gridded um there's a
gridded product from
the points and this is all the points
being of a glacier so you're tracking
like
how glaciers change over time how they
move
how much they move through all of that
technology
it sounds a lot kind of just like data
science honestly like you have a lot of
data and you're trying to get the
patterns from that using all of it
i think honestly just how they move
is still a question
is still a question of debate in a sense
in glaciology because glaciology is
still a pretty
immature field like meaning like it
like modern glaciology is kind of
founded in the 50s compared to like you
know physics or mathematics only like
thousands
yeah years yeah with at least what i do
with lidar um
i study that process of glacier to
iceberg called caffeine
just like a cow calves a baby cow like a
glacier calves nice yeah that's so
perfect
and calving understanding that process
calving
one you want to parameterize that so we
could project future rates of sea level
rise
also simply just how ice fractures is
still
debatable like there's not really it's
kind of hard to measure these things in
the field because again the scales are
so large
and they're also hard to get to yeah
yeah
one of the biggest stereotypes is kind
of what you point out like ice pick
on an ice sheet and to be fair that's
just kind of how the field's presented
i mean it's not accurate but that's just
what i'd say that's probably the most
common thing
and i'll say that's pretty bad
misrepresentation of the field because
glaciologists don't have to go
on greenland and antarctica like most of
us work
in a ide like spider or something and on
a computer dividing code
to process this data and or model
glacier behavior
and so it's really more computational
than field based
i would say and that's kind of why i
wanted to do this anyways too because
i'm like i never thought i was myself as
that different from your community
yeah until i kind of pointed out like
hey you're different i was like
oh yeah
that's a good question because like i
said before i wanted to be like the
silicon valley software engineering life
growing up at least in high school
in early college and would i change that
now
um i still want to stay in academia i
think my trajectory would be finding a
postdoc and then
finding a tenure track position knock on
wood somewhere but i have entertained
the thought of doing more of like a
open source geospatial software
developing gig no no when i'm done with
my phd hopefully i could do something
like that because i work with a lot of
um software developers too and i really
like the open source geospatial
software dev community they're a lot of
fun yeah does
is does it my first guess is that it
gets like that kind of technology gets
used in stuff like vr
but like how kind of tell me more about
that i don't think i know very much
about
geospatial in the sense of like mapping
things
in the world how do you know where
something is
in space and how you express that with
data
and like how can you model it in
software
i'm guessing exactly like so solving
problems like
how much like that there's like the
commercials like how much crappy
they're gonna have when you have like
like the ibm commercials or something
like that like that's
using like a gis and a remote sensing
based system
it sounds like a really direct
application of programming
to the rest of the world it's like
literally how do you bridge that gap
because you are trying to create like
modern
the reality in which we live in onto
computers
it's yeah isn't it like wild that it's
like you know we all talk about
programming and coding as if it's this
one thing but like
the way that you use it and the other
skills around it
are like really define kind of what you
do
because like you and i we write code but
like for massively different ways and
like if i sat in your scene you sat in
my seat we'd both just be like i don't
know what's going on
[Music]
that's that's tough and that's a good
question um i guess i can only speak
from my experiences and myself if you
are
if you love technology and you like
coding but
you don't want to necessarily follow the
silicon valley
software engineer route then i think
there's some really good transferable
skills you have
in the earth sciences or in the
geospatial community
and so maybe you can look somewhere else
and apply your skills there and also
the problems it's still problem solving
nonetheless it's really cool and
i think the community needs people like
my yuko's audience earlier to
tackle these problems not necessarily
glaciology if you're really interested
in glaciers ice and climate change
then by all means look into it and you
can even contact me please
well there are a lot of challenges in
academia honestly there's a lot of um
barriers and you see a lot of more like
bad things like swept under the rug i
feel like the higher you go
in academia as far as um diversity
issues and we'll just di jedi in general
sometimes you might have a great mentor
i'm thankful that i have
a great mentor in my advisors um and i
can't speak an industry i'm assuming
it's kind of prevalent everywhere but
specifically in academia can be really
hard also it's just a huge privilege
because you don't make as much money as
you would in the industry
you're kind of just fueled by your
mentorship self-motivation
and that's like that's kind of like how
much it keeps you going um and then
maybe that gets sick and tired after a
while and the positions just aren't
readily available so you have to really
dedicate yourself
and if that's not for you hopefully you
can find it out in industry
when you were deciding to go for your
phd in glaciology like
considering all those factors were you
like you know what i still
really freaking like glaciers so i'm
gonna do it like what was your thought
process in that
so honestly it was probably a little bit
of hubris i was like probably way too
overconfident
at first i was like but i'm ultimately
glad i still made a decision um i just
love
learning i guess in academic settings
too not even just about science or stem
fields but like being in that
environment where i could like go
learn about some classics or like watch
like a poetry reading or
do something like that i kind of just
like that environment i don't know it's
fun too because you're really
independent as a phd student like i can
like oh like i've
i've never used this python package i
don't know this technology let me just
spend a day or two learning it you know
there's no one like
screaming at me that i have to do
something else at that time i'm just you
know
yeah kind of thinking of my own
applications to solve a problem right
by myself and like i just consult with
my advisor yeah that flexibility sounds
really nice and not something that you
can find anywhere in the industry for
sure
thank you everybody so much for watching
i hope you enjoyed it
if you like this series and you want to
see more definitely leave a comment down
below and thank you so much
again to my friend michael for being in
my video and as always don't forget to
like and subscribe this video it doesn't
necessarily help the algorithm or
something but
i'm almost at 400k subscribers and i'd
love to have you be one of them
i hope that y'all are doing well and
staying safe and taking care
and i will see you next time bye